hey friends of the podcast and welcome
to all of our new listeners this
is rotten tomatoes is wrong i'm mark
ellis stand up comic and rotten tomatoes
correspondent
and i'm jacqueline coley i'm an editor
at rotten tomatoes where i cover
independent film and awards and where i
will defend the movie love actually
until my dying breath okay well if we're
defending love actually then i'll tell
you what we're gonna do jaclyn because
look we promised our listeners last week
that we were going to do how the grinch
stole christmas the jim carrey version
this week but we just decided to
not get grinchy with it quite yet we
didn't want to talk about the whos
and dr seuss until we really got to the
the crux of the christmas conversation
seemingly every year
is love actually a fresh
movie now according to the tomato meter
it is
with both the tomato meter and the
audience score it's 64
on the tomato meter audience score is
even better at 72 percent and so
we had to postpone the grinch i'm sure
he's not gonna be upset about it because
we are talking about
love actually today and we have not one
not one no no no no this is love
actually folks it's a movie about like
38 different characters so we needed two
special guests to come up here
and talk with myself and jacqueline
about this film it's kind of like an
episode of versus jaclyn so before we
bring
those special guests on can you just
give all of us a refresher as to
what love actually is about and i'm so
happy you're the one that has to do this
today
well love actually is about a group
of british slash uk folks that are five
weeks away from christmas and when we
open
we believe that these are individual
stories about
love the opening shot is at heathrow
airport where richard curtis said that
he
found that love is actually everywhere
some of the vignettes that we get to see
are hugh grant as the prime minister
uh wooing a very monica lewinsky type uh
catering assistant we also have liam
neeson who is a fresh widower
with his young stepson who's also in
love with the lovely joanna from his
school we have colin firth
being colin firth and being lovely in
that and we have laura linney one of the
few americans in the piece
well being adorable and laura linney
again this is all about folks finding
love in unexpected places
and you get a little bill nye half naked
uh yeah you know i'm sorry bill bill
niley half naked
not bill nye the science guy hey why not
bring on bill nye the science guy too
because this movie has everybody their
brother and their sister in it and like
jacqueline said
everyone is looking for love but did we
the audience
find said emotion we're about to get
into all that today and helping us do
that
is a man who you know you love him he's
a long time film critic
moderator he's currently the critic for
ktla channel 5 which is the news channel
here in los angeles he's done so many
different things with us at rotten
tomatoes he has a new youtube channel
that bears his name
he is the cosmic ball of energy known as
the mance man scott mance welcome back
to the show how you doing pal
i am so happy to be here with all of you
it doesn't matter that i'm gonna have to
get a little grinchy with this
particular film because the point is is
that
i love a great conversation i love a
great conversation
with my friends my peers my colleagues
people that i really do
love and respect if love is all around
it's right here on this podcast the love
that i have for each and every one of
you
so let's just get that make that clear
before i uh get a little grinchy on this
hill
hey you know what it's fine if you tip
your hand because that's why we
have the deck stacked appropriately this
is gonna be a two on two battle
and to help one of our sides
is our steam producer who we love having
on the show each and every week she
is none other than lucy now lucy i'm
just looking
at our zoom call here today and i see in
the background
a festive christmas tree it looks like
you live in one of those
nice london flats that you would see and
love actually
was that the goal of your interior
decorating this season um
i was inspired by this movie yes i do
not live in an expensive london flat hi
everybody by the way
i live in a very old uh
crusty cockroach-infested building in
koreatown but i love it it's great
oh well don't worry lucy i'm sure
there's going to be some british man and
is
approaching his 40s that's going to come
by and sweep you off your feet any
minute now
until that hat and we'll see how that
works out with your husband until that
happens i want to stay with you first
lucy because if we're going to say
rotten tomatoes is right or rotten
tomatoes is wrong you're the producer of
this show
i want to give you the floor here the
tomato meter says
that love actually is a fresh movie is
lucy bruckner in agreement with that
statement
i am so behind this
score rotten tomatoes is incredibly
right this time you guys
to argue otherwise is nonsensical
it is a fresh film and it deserves the
64
that it has and now
we play tennis right back to scott man
scott do you agree with
lucy rotten tomatoes being right or do
you have maybe a different take
lucy i love you to pieces i respect you
beyond belief i respect jacqueline
beyond belief i
i love respect mark ellis beyond belief
love
actually when i first saw this film
when it came out on november 14
2003 when this movie was over
i said this movie should be called love
actually
not this movie was rotten
i hated this movie it was a good thing
that i ate all my popcorn because i had
an empty tub that i was ready
to vomit into i hated this movie okay
i've eaten the movie theaters before and
i've taken down a large corn or two and
sometimes i feel like vomiting just
because i ate too much popcorn but other
times the movie can induce that sort of
feeling
i'm looking at you transformers so now
we're gonna go over to jacqueline
coley jacqueline you know that i have
dear love for you
do you have dear love for love actually
i
do but i will say my love for more love
actually though
as much as i appreciate lucy's undying
love and there are
moments when i'm on the lucy train that
like this is just
joyous also i just i'm gonna circle back
to why
moviemance hates christmas because that
was some frenchness
how can you look at thomas brodie
sangster
drumming his little heart out for that
little mixed race child
and not fall in love how how i mean in a
minute
on in the show scott can defend his take
on all the drummer boys that are on all
the stages in britain
for me this is why we're all doing this
show together is that i have to ally
with my brother scott mance here i don't
think that this is a
a i don't hate this movie the way scott
does i i actually can find a lot of
redeeming value in love actually
and i can sit down and i can enjoy it i
find a lot of good comedic moments in
here
i appreciate the spirit i like some of
the cameos we get to see
but overall i just do not think that
this movie a stands the test of time
and i also think that it's not a holiday
classic which is
partially why i can get a little grinchy
about it it's not that it's a bad movie
but it's definitely that it's not some
sort of classic that your family needs
to gather around and watch
every holiday season i feel like this
movie's just
jammed down our throats with those
all-time classics with your christmas
carols with your
your it's a wonderful lives and i just
don't think it's there
so basically you're saying love actually
can't sit with us at the christmas table
what actually if there's only mean girls
there's only one seat left and that seat
was occupied
by tim bless his heart he was no longer
with actually well we do have our own
tim on the show so maybe we should throw
it to him first
not tiny tim who in an alternate reality
didn't make it don't worry folks at the
end of a christmas carol tim does make
it
and this tim our own tim ryan expert
review curator here at rotten tomatoes
made it to this show so tim why don't
you tell us
what the critics were saying about love
actually
when it came out was there any popcorn
vomiting
being spewed back in 2003 thank you mark
so love actually is at 64
on the tomato meter with 221 reviews
with a 72
audience score what's interesting about
love actually is that it
still has a sort of split response from
audiences where there's some people who
just like it is a perennial holiday
classic and they just
love it and there's other people who not
only don't like it but think it's aged
terribly
but what did the critics have to say
about it when it came out um
a lot of them who liked it were like
this is charming this is like
cozy it's got a tinge of melancholy and
the performances are really good this is
a really comfy
well done romantic comedy on the other
hand the critics
didn't like it felt like it tried way
too hard to be a feel-good movie and
ends up just being really saccharine
that the story lines really jumbled
and that it didn't rise above romantic
comedy cliches
so what did critics have to say
specifically in a fresh review roger
ebert from the chicago sun times wrote
the movie's only flaw is also a virtue
it's jammed with characters
stories warmth and laughs until at times
curtis seems to be working from a
checklist of obligatory movie love
situations and doesn't want to leave
anything out
on the other hand in a rotten review
carla meyer of the san francisco
chronicle wrote love actually curtis's
holiday theme directing debut abandons
any pretext of sophistication for gloppy
sentimentality
sugary pop songs and body humor an
approach that works about
half the time so anyway is love actually
the ideal romantic comedy or is it just
another romantic comedy
i don't know where you fall but i'll
tell you that all i want for christmas
is from mark and jacqueline
to get along during this episode it'll
be a christmas miracle
back to you guys go to your room tim
your mother and i are fighting right now
wow but wait a minute first of all tim
when mommy and daddy fight just remember
we always love you
[Laughter]
but it's for those look for those
keeping score at home just remember
on the in the sandwich of love actually
lucy is on the very very very far right
love love love love love i am a little
left of her
with love but questions because i always
have questions
mark is on the dislike slash love
more closer to scott mans and scott
mance
is way over in siberia with his cold
cold heart
i just want to know where i just want
everyone to know where everyone is
before we get into it so i don't think
mommy and daddy are going to fight as
hard as they think
i i got to say jacqueline you're
absolutely right to point out just
how how much we are all coming from very
very different points of view on this
movie
we all have a completely different take
and listening to that summation right
now
of the of the critics and reading uh
roger ebert's a very good review in the
san francisco chronicle
uh very bad review i do agree with
some of what roger had to say uh say i i
agree with all of what the san francisco
chronicle had to say my goodness
and let's be clear here we're talking
about a film where the rotten tomatoes
rating
is 64 not
94 64 so even though
it is fresh it is not certified fresh
and it is also just a few points above
being rotten so it is kind of a
mixed review mixed positive
which is where i guess uh jaclyn you are
in the film yeah mixed to positive i
mean it's
and i'm and i'm mixed to negative and so
to borrow a line from one of scott's
favorite movies return of the jedi
it's it's from a certain point of view
here and so i'm looking
at this and i see a 64 of the tomato
meter
as rotten adjacent whereas jaclyn might
see it as
as fresh barely fresh but it's still
fresh so you just leave that barely off
so let's start with a positive though
because i i do find redeeming qualities
about this movie
and i can enjoy if this was a rotten
movie i probably wouldn't think about it
as much and i probably wouldn't have it
shoved into my face every holiday season
but i don't think that i would have
harbored nearly the resentment that i
have
because it is fresh though jacqueline
what's a scene for you
that that typifies why this is such a
good movie well there's a lot
but i i do think and i hate to jump to
the end
because it's you know it's kind of
anti-climactic
i definitely want to stop in laura
linney stomping her feet
when she is finally you know she's
fallen in love with the carl the
tech guy from her office alan rickman
has played matchmaker
and she's like dancing and she's like
love that
however the penultimate best moment is
definitely the all i want for christmas
with joanna singing it
there's so much that goes on in this
first of all tony brodie uh
thomas brodie sangster learned how to
play the drums
let's also talk about the fact that the
girl that plays joanna
her voice was so good they had to dumb
that stuff down
and when she points at him
and he points back with his little drum
thingy
die love love love and then like the
climax of course first of all
sister i'm hoping she's the musical
teacher coming with the background
vocals to just make it
even better um then at the end hugh
grant and his little monica lewinsky
girl natalie they make out how can you
if you were mad by that point i don't
understand if you even know
christmas right
so not quite as secret as we'd hoped
what do we do now
smile a little bow
[Applause]
wait hang on just
a new york minute jaclyn coley
you know i i do want to say that that
there
are a couple things about the film that
i actually did like
for me the storyline that i've loved
above all the others
by by far and this would have been just
a great movie on its own
was bill nye uh i
thought he was as as billy mac this sort
of cross between mick jagger and robert
palmer
i thought he was hilarious i love the
relationship between him and his manager
that to me felt genuine in a film
that was loaded and i mean loaded
to the rim with contrivances
and manipulation i felt like i was being
force fed a spoonful of sugar
every minute of this movie and none of
it
rang true some of it was back then
i thought really kind of i guess a
little
creepy like when you have andrew lincoln
stalking uh kara knightley the younger
brother i love
andrew lincoln is fine and he was hiding
behind a beard in the walking dead so
the andrew lincoln the andrew lincoln
thing is something that i think we're
going to get to later on in the show
just because that is a very
hotly contested debated moment in the
movie
and it might be one of those this is why
i think this film is rotten
but scott did give us a good reason for
why you could like the movie which is
bill nye alone lucy i mean this guy
he's in a recording studio we meet him
early and we get to know who this guy
is and so part of me watching the rest
of the movie is like okay but can we
just go back to bill
because i i kind of miss what bill's
doing right now give me another reason
lucy or a scene
or a storyline why love actually is
beloved so
guys first and foremost we need to go
back to the very beginning
and before i tell you what it is that i
think really kicks this movie off
we need to have a discussion briefly
about
what types of love there are
because when you're asking the question
which this movie asks right which is
what is love actually right there's
actually
different types according to ancient
greeks even right
we've got philia which is affectionate
love this is
love between friends and family there's
eros which is romantic love
there's mania which is obsessive love
kafka andrew lincoln keira knightley's
storyline
and then there's agape which is selfless
love i have a theory
that richard curtis literally just
googled types of love
and then slotted in different storylines
according to each type i think there's
like seven or eight
that's exactly what he did lucy yeah and
but you know what
i think it's brilliant because when
people think of love they usually just
think of arrows like romantic love like
this movie isn't about love and this
movie sucks and all these horrible
things happen
well guess what it actually is about
love and the scene for me that really
kind of encapsulates all of that right
is the very opening start of the movie
which is
the airport montage and you're seeing
all these potentially i think they're
like real people
at heathrow airport in london hugging
and kissing and reuniting
i'm an emotional airpor airport goer so
it just immediately brings back all
those memories for me of when i've
reunited with my family and friends
after a trip away or
visiting my mom back in nebraska when i
haven't seen her for two years so
it already sets the tone for me
emotionally but then it's the voice over
from hugh grant right who plays the
prime minister in the film
and he says this thing i'm gonna just
read it really quickly that i think is
brilliant
and i think this is why it's a good film
which is ultimately
you know we live here goes we live in a
world of hatred and greed
this terrible british accent but i don't
see that seems to me that love is
everywhere
often it's not dignified or newsworthy
but it's always there
mothers and sons husbands and wives
boyfriends and girlfriends
when the planes hit the tren the twin
towers most messages weren't of hate or
revenge
they were all messages of love if you
look for it
i've got a sneaky feeling that love
actually is all around
whenever i get gloomy with the state of
the world i think about the arrivals
gate at heathrow airport
general opinions starting to make out
that we live in a world of hatred and
greed
but i don't see that seems to me that
love is everywhere
excuse my terrible hugh grant wait
shitty impersonation lucy lucy that was
a great emma thompson
thank you that was actually a really
good
at least by my standards it was a great
british accent the problem is that she
was doing hugh grant's speech which when
the movie kicks off i love it
i enjoy most of it i i want to go back
to the time period where
this was actually written by richard
curtis because to be fair to him lucy
there's no way that he could have
googled
love and the different meanings he
probably asked jeeves
back in 2001 or 2002.
but it's also like i i'm not a huge fan
of movies if you want to make a war
movie that's about a war that was 50 or
80 years ago
fine manipulate my emotions like 1917.
that's
that's that's fair game two years after
911 to bring 911 up in the opening
monologue in the opening montage can we
just
do we have to go there already it just
so now i'm already in a weird mood
and i i like the spirit of this is the
airport because i'm a different kind of
airport goer i
am the airport sucker and that i'm the
guy that will give you a ride to the
airport
i'm the guy that will still say yes i'm
the guy that will park the car
and pay the fee and then meet you at
baggage claim instead of just meeting
you with the curb and rushing you into
my
2020. it doesn't give you tingly
feelings it doesn't give you
like warm ugh it does but the scene
the scene in this movie that i say oh
this is why this
could have been a great movie is emma
thompson
but it's not her celebrating love it's
her heart breaking it's the scene
where she is going full oscar emma
thompson
and she has realized now that her
husband might be cheating on her
earlier in the day on christmas eve she
comes home
and her husband is now home and she just
reaches into his jacket pocket
innocently pulls out
what she thinks is going to be a
necklace for her later on that evening
and then she sees a present wrapped
under the tree
and she says oh oh this is probably that
thing so then they gather the kitties
around and it's time to open one
christmas eve present my family has the
same tradition so we're exchanging gifts
and that's the one she wants because she
wants to prove to herself
nay her entire family that alan rickman
still loves her and this necklace is
going to be a token of that and she
opens it up and it's a goddamn joni
mitchell cd
now she did say she like joining me so
alan rickman
did have you know some feelings toward
it because like hey i know you're like
joni mitchell here you go
but she realized in that moment that her
husband's eye
was drifting if not other parts of his
body and so she goes into the bedroom
and she has a moment by herself to watch
her compose herself because this is also
an example of love
is that she loves her family so much she
doesn't want to break down in front of
them and ruin christmas for the kids
so she sucks it up and she uses her love
as strength for the family
at least for the time being that is a
scene to me
that i'm like oh ooh okay that's really
good stuff
but the rest of the film just kind of
deviates and
and and has tropes and and gets a little
cheap at times which are things that i
can buy into in romantic comedy scott
but
when you're throwing that much at me
it's a little hard to swallow okay first
of all
i'm glad you brought up emma thompson
because to me
she was the only real fully
realized complexed uh
real human being in this movie and and
she stayed with him she did not really
let him have it
you know by the end of the film they're
they're still together i guess being
married is it to somebody who doesn't
love her
or is not faithful to her is better than
than
not being married at all and and you
know being true to yourself and finding
someone that you actually deserve
uh that was a great moment that was a
real
genuine moment the the moment that i
really felt like was
really stood out as being real in a film
that was
i think two hours and 15 minutes full of
one contrivance after another
also also full of just
so many and i noticed this when i
re-watched the movie
recently for this uh rt is wrong podcast
and discovering things about the movie
that have not aged well
particularly it's the way it has it has
uh
treated its female characters so many of
them
are submissive and uh
they are not treated well they're
treated like objects
they're marginalized uh look at the way
hugh grant prime minister on his very
first day he's already hitting on
uh i i think the actress named martine
mccutchen
like the first day really and the way
that
really quick i think he hits on all the
staff even the guy
butler but it's it's it's also like
like colin firth oh but he has this uh
uh housekeeper who doesn't speak a word
english but it's okay she's hot she's
gonna take off her clothes before she
jumps in the water
i mean i couldn't believe just how
degrading
this movie has has become
over time the way it is you see the
movie that way
it's unfair to its female cast many of
them who are working for the males that
they end up falling for yes
yes yes by the way first of all
i not to bring up a different you know
thing tail
is old as time
this is what's so crazy it's not that
you don't think that this love exists
you just don't think it should be
glorified in a christmas movie
in the sense of like okay what's up with
laura linney she's not
whatever she's a caring person who's
taking care of her brother who's
she's a caregiver she's not a doormat
and the natalie character
i don't know what you're talking about
she
is the one that goes after him she's the
one that's trying to pursue him she's
the one that's like i watch
she tries to get rid of her twice she
tries to get rid of her twice the moment
he
looks at her and he walks in the door he
walks in the door
and he's like whoa okay and by the way
what's with all the jokes about
natalie's weight why did so many
why were there so many running jokes
about how she's plus
by the way i don't disagree with you
because that is that if i had to pick a
scene scott that i that really bothers
me about this movie one of the reasons
why
i find it so off-putting is as a
chubby fat kid growing up it this movie
almost has a message where
uh if you are in shape if you have
uh if you look good then you deserve
love
if you're heavy then hopefully you can
trip into it and get lucky somehow
because colin firth shows up to the door
of his portuguese maid's house
and the father answers and he says i'm
in love with you i want to marry your
daughter
and the heavier daughter reveals herself
and it's like oh no no no not that
daughter
and it just plays like
oh okay because she's not gonna deserve
it and the movie tries to pass it off as
she her and her dad have this running
joke about her weight that i just i i do
not understand
the fun in that and i'm trying to not be
too
sensitive about this but it's hard to
not when the movie continually reminds
you of that like i see no problem with
how natalie
looks i i don't see any she's not
somebody that i would say
oh let's cast her as the person who
needs to lose weight in order to find
hugh grant it's just
none of that makes sense to me and the
movie keeps reminding you
that there's flaws with these people
particularly with these women and i
i don't get it it's the school christmas
concert you see david
is the first time all the local schools
have joined together even some basil
too much detail anyway how can we help
sir
well i just needed
natalie
[Music]
on some state business oh
right yes of course
right uh well perhaps you should uh come
on later plumpy
natalie i agree with you completely mark
i think you really hit the nail on the
head
and you know re-watching this movie uh
obviously because i didn't like it when
i saw it in 2003 and i actually did see
it twice i saw it at a press screening
and then i saw it uh you know when it
opened with a with a woman i i had uh
asked out on a date
she loved the movie i didn't we never
saw each other again
and i and i have not wait was that
because of the movie was that because
you vomited into your popcorn bucket
immediately after
the date well i don't think she saw the
vomit part because she had gone on but
uh
but you know we went out to dinner after
the movie you know and
and uh you know we were talking about
the film and she was going on about how
much she loved it
and i was going you know i'm trying to
be like like you know
respectful and everything and finally i
just could not take it anymore i just
said i cannot believe you loved that
movie that was like the worst movie i've
ever seen
every romantic comedy cliche that was
ever ever
ever written is all there in one
ridiculously contrived manipulative
force-fed movie
and i wasn't even hungry because i felt
like i had eaten so much sugar
throughout the throughout the course of
that month but scott scott and mark
here's the question though
yes i just like jaclyn said like we're
not pro fat shaming
are there some misogynistic things and
kind of like iffy
lady man dynamics in the movie yes
but what's the message of the movie what
is love all about
love is usually found in the small
things there are so many moments in this
movie that
like the laura linney storyline to
jaclyn's point like she decides to
to sacrifice a romantic relationship for
herself so that she can take care of her
brother
and there are two americans kind of
stuck in london and he's this mentally
ill guy
and she decides to care for him
which is like the deepest kind of love
right the self-sacrificial love
that storyline alone to me message-wise
like
like overcomes all the fat shaming and
all the
problems with it so don't you guys
that's that'd be it's a great wait a
minute
moment hold on on the fat shaming side
let's just also say for being the movie
that yes she is five ounces above
anorexic she's not even even remotely
chubby but they're trying to play a game
and she does have to be the object of
affection so i get it's cast in a
certain way
however let's be honest this is the same
hollywood that called drew barrymore fat
for the same body frame that natalie has
so it's not as if they were particularly
i think saying that she actually is fat
it's more
this is what people have projected as
the ideal thing of beauty and in the end
she gets arguably the hottest hunk in
the gig
so right afterwards reminds her that her
nickname is plumpy
and like thank you there's certain
there's certain story lines that you can
look at and say that's what true love is
so
lucy makes a great point it's the laura
linney caring for her brother that's
awesome
i saw a better version of that in a
super bowl commercial last year
that told us what agape love was and i'm
like okay that's a nice short message
and i didn't have to sit through a two
and a half hour movie
that's disguising itself as christmas i
think that's really
the issue that i have with this film is
that it's like it's saying that
that christmas isn't this holiday to be
celebrated on its own
it's this holiday to force feed any love
fantasy you've ever had in your life
and see it to fruition this movie treats
christmas like it's valentine's day i
never looked at christmas as your last
chance
to get your true love feelings out
christmas was the time for me to like
see my family and it's like to hang out
with your fam and just like
maybe text someone that you think is hot
it's not a time
to go running into the street and and go
door to door by the way you're the prime
minister look up her
address you weirdo thank you
all right wait the other thing okay to
your point mr mark ellis
can we talk okay you know i i have
definitely
seen on this recent viewing you know i
was i was completely shocked
and surprised by by how
how obvious the the fat shaming sort of
came to the fore on this recent viewing
also just how
the movie really oh overall i mean not
every storyline
but overall the movie does paint a
degrading
depiction towards women and nowhere
better is that scene on the chris
marshall storyline where he can't
meet a girl in london so he goes to
america
to get laid because american women are
hotter and they're also
stupider i've just worked out why i can
never find true love
why is that english girl they're stuck
up you see
then i am primarily attractive to girls
who are you know cooler
game for laughs like american girls
so i should just go to america i would
get a girlfriend there instantly
what do you think i think it's crap
colin
that's why you're wrong american girls
would seriously dig me with my cute
british accent
you don't have a cute british accent yes
i do i'm going to america colin
you're a lonely ugly [ __ ] and you
must accept it
never i am colin god of sex i'm just on
the wrong continent absolutely
not his assertion wait hang on hang on
jacqueline
the other thing is that if if that
doesn't
uh paint a depiction that boy americans
are really stupid and the other thing
is that uh you have a president
portrayed by billy bob thornton
who's a royal part of the expression
[ __ ] and placed every bad president
stereotype in the book
it is an anti-american movie and it is
also an anti-woman
movie so there you go lies laura linney
again
one of the best people in the play
richard curtis literally could not find
anybody better
and he was just like i want a laura
linney type they're like the casting
director's like get laura linney
she's an american she's in the piece
she's
fabulous joanna another awesome
literally has the showstopper
she's an american it's not anti-american
are there issues problems with it yes
andrew
lincoln's character is a hot mess and a
half
for thirsting after his friend's first
girlfriend
then fiance then wife like the moments
for him to get off the track on this
were like
way far ahead however if i had to say
which i think is the worst part of the
movie it's actually the alan rickman
stuff
because first of all why is he playing
matchmaker
and like office [ __ ] man
with that office tart i don't even know
what that actress's name is i'm sure
she's a lovely person but i hate her
ponies lucia muniz yeah sure she's a
lovely lady despise her in this movie
at the end when she's prancing around in
her underwear with that necklace that
she
so undeservingly got all i think to
myself is
to quote the famous nene leakes close
your legs to married
men close your legs to married men take
that necklace put it down there and
cool your fanny i'll use the english
parlance
and stay away from him it's so gross
which she does she is the character
where i'm like
this is so unbelievable that and the
fact that that kid could learn how to
play the drums in three weeks jacqueline
knows herself to your point jaclyn the
thought going on in my head was just
like this is
not the snape i signed up for i did i
i am not i do not like this snape
version i really don't and he looks
kind of i don't like oh the turtlenecks
like
he but at least you're not supposed to
to like that character i mean
alan rickman historically played great
villains
he was hans gruber um you know the
sheriff of nottingham
he's played awesome bad guys before and
so you buy him in that role
and while i think bill nye is a great
example of why this movie does work
despite your misgivings about the
character themselves because not
everybody needs to have strong moral
fiber to be
someone that you honestly can root for
in a movie
the andrew lincoln stuff is serial
killers to me the american
female stuff where the there's an
there's a british dude who just cannot
have any luck with ladies in his own
country and so he says i need to go to
america i need to meet myself a real
cowgirl so he goes to wisconsin
and as soon as he gets off the plane he
meets four ladies that are just so happy
to hop in bed with him and get naked
with him in their one bedroom apartment
now any time i have heard any story
remotely similar to that from my
comedian buddies who've been on the road
that is immediately followed with i
passed out and they had stolen my wallet
my tv and my playstation 4.
so i and i hadn't seen this movie in so
long that i forgot that it didn't end up
like that that it actually did end
happy for that dude so god bless him
it's such a small minuscule part of the
movie that it wouldn't bother me if
all these other things didn't add up
it's all these different strands
that they're weaving into this tapestry
that i don't need any of them to go too
deep but what i would like is more
characters to have some sort of
redeeming value liam neeson
and his stepson i can root for them i
can root for laura winnie i can root for
emma thompson
and i can certainly root for the scene
stealer of this entire film
mr rowan atkinson directed by richard
curtis
in being as far back as black adder and
richard curtis's tv day
so i was very happy to see rowan
atkinson pop up i thought he killed it
and
according to our expert researcher mark
hoffmeyer apparently there was a version
of this story early on where rowan
atkinson was going to keep popping into
each story and he was going to be sort
of the angel of christmas
and i do wonder maybe that would have
taken away from the other storylines
but i also wonder if that would have
made it feel more christmassy and less
valentine's day
because that's what i keep coming back
to as i don't understand the correlation
between all these stories happening in
winter time
necessarily being that of a great
christmas flick so
i want to start with lucy and then i
want to go around the panel here because
the broader question of this film
as we get into more talk about the
surrounding feelings of the movie
is that this is a film that people
either love or they
hate and it's also been described as the
mcdonald's of romantic comedy so
lucy how do you respond to this movie
that is so
polarizing and could be considered fast
food
so just so you know i eat mcdonald's
like once or twice a week so
i love it it's delicious if you shame me
for it whatever i don't care
if we want to compare this to mcdonald's
if we want to compare love actually to
this film
fine it's delicious it makes a lot of
money
it's gonna be around forever and i will
love it till i die
but so i did read that you know
richard curtis like really loves
christmas and it's kind of like the
secondary thing so the argument about
you know is this a good christmas movie
or not for me it doesn't really matter
like you could call it a valentine's day
movie you could call it a christmas
movie
for me it's just a story about love so i
will watch it at any point in the year
it's not just a christmas flick for me
one of the things i think that shows the
power
going back to like mr bean for example
uh rowan atkinson
one of the things and scenes actually
that to me
just shows you kind of how clever and
brilliant the movie really is is
alan rickman mr shipball is
looking for some jewelry for his
potential side piece right
and his assistant and he's at the store
with his wife emma thompson and she's
looking for some presents
and then he decides i'm going to buy
this beautiful gold heart necklace
and who's the guy that's going to wrap
the gift but rowan atkinson
and it's a scene that unfolds where he's
trying to hurry and buy the gift so that
his wife doesn't see his little
infidelity that's not a word but
behavior
and rowan atkinson is taking his sweet
ass time right just
could i put some you know you know rose
petals in it sir
oh you asked for the gift wrapping that
whole thing
what a brilliant scene because i'm equal
parts wanting to die inside and i'm
nervous and i'm horrified but i'm also
laughing
to get that kind of emotional duality in
a scene
is brilliant writing and brilliant
performing
would you like it gift wrapped
uh yes lovely
let me just pop it in the box
there look could we be quite quick
certainly sir ready in the flashiest of
flashes
so i will watch that any time of year
there are so many moments like that in
this movie that just make it really good
actually
problems aside so i'm on the bandwagon
that this is a good film
i understand that and i can like
mcdonald's too i actually might have
been to mcdonald's last week
ordered spicy mcnuggets only to find out
they had already discontinued that
delicious menu item
and my heart was broken jacqueline is
this movie fast food and is that
a fair criticism of the movie uh
no i don't think it's a fair criticism
to call it fast food it definitely has
some qualities where maybe you shouldn't
eat it as often
this is what it is with love actually
love actually
is a perfect romantic comedy set
in christmas but if we're being really
honest christmas is really more like an
overlay it really is it's not
the heart of the story and so i think
that's why people like you have an issue
with it is its casting as a christmas
movie because yes
it does have obviously christmas
elements but not to bring up this debate
but if we're really talking about the
spirit of christmas
it's not so much about the romantic love
that we see in love actually
it is much more about like the love that
we see
in the smaller moments of it like the
the laura linney aspect and
you know the love that you know liam
neeson's character has for his son for
helping him try to win the girl that he
wants to be with
so i don't think that it's fast food
there's an article that thankfully
mark hoffmeier always keeps us up to
date with all the right information
and he told us about you know people
that have to defend
their love for this movie because it's
it's one of those issues as lucy will
probably tell you
not a lot of people are down with it and
if they hate it they really want to tell
you
but it's a pretty perfect romantic
comedy
if that's what it is and that's the part
it's a pretty
perfect romantic comedy it is a
piss-poor
christmas movie okay tell him jacqueline
get it
i'm listening and and romantic comedies
are saccharine they're predictable
they're
with weird situations and originally it
was supposed to be two romantic comedies
anyway
one with colin firth one with hugh grant
they couldn't make either one of the
movies they shoved it all together and
then they created all of these
multi-linear storylines for romantic
movies that gary marshall
made a mint out of you know what scott
this movie to me feels like
there's a great scene in the big short
where
the amazing and unfortunately late chef
anthony bourdain is
explaining how the the market got
shorted right
and he's talking about it like making a
stew and so if you have this delicious
chicken dish that you made
on wednesday you can no longer serve
that chicken dish by saturday
however what you can do is you can chop
up that chicken
and you can dump it into a bucket of
stew and now you have a delicious
chicken stew
because that chicken wasn't good enough
to survive
on its own on a plate as the primary
meal but
nobody's gonna care about chicken that
may be past its prime
if you just put a big hunk of it into a
stew and you give all these other
ingredients people aren't gonna notice
that the chicken
is a little suspect that's how i feel
about this movie and i feel
like the hate for this movie has only
grown out of other people
loving it so much so i feel like this is
a movie that's just fine
but because we continually have this
debate every year
those stronger emotions tend to pop up
where people either fervently defend it
because they feel forced or people
fervently hate it because they feel like
it's being shoved down their throat is
that your take on the on the film as
well
okay well first of all uh you know in
regards to the movie being fast food you
know i i respect
the mcdonald's lovers here i've always
been more of an in-n-out burger kind of
guy
uh second of all with regards to anthony
bourdain describing this
as a stew when it comes to turning a
movie into a stew where you have multi
story lines
yes gary marshall did capitalize that in
more recent years before he passed on
but the ultimate chef
with that kind of stew is actually
robert
altman with his 1975 movie nashville
he created this multi-character
multi-story overlapping uh
uh masterpiece that has been
uh uh has influenced so many filmmakers
obviously richard curtis obviously gary
marshall but also
also a paul thomas anderson uh with
magnolia
and when it's done right it works when
it's done right you know the uh
the uh the connections they they feel
right and this movie they they don't
feel right they feel
they feel contrived you know the other
thing about
richard curtis as a writer is i think he
is a better writer than he is
as a director he wrote for weddings at a
funeral
i i love that movie i love bridget
jones's diary
and also uh notting hill i loved and
uh last year the beatles movie yesterday
he wrote it
but he did he did not direct that movie
um now
as a director i don't think he fares as
well i think his shortcomings as
his director are are more prominent in
love actually
and also in the film in time which is a
movie i like but it's not
it's not focused it's very uneven it
starts off about time about time about
about time anytime is the very very
maligned
justin timberlake futuristic movie so
if i had to take in time versus about
time i am taking the closet time travel
movie
by richard curtis all day and all night
okay about time yes uh and no you know
that was a film that i liked
uh but again as a director it was it was
on focus and it turned into something
very different in the end
so love actually uh you know his heart
is in the right place and again i love
him as a writer
but uh i just felt that like does this
movie just tried
it tried too hard the stew
was was uh full of too much sugar and it
just did not
go down well and it also it also weight
it also has not aged well
i think uh and also with regards to how
how mark you point out how where people
are having to defend this movie every
year and other people are
are digging their their their feet into
the ground
with their stance like the one that i
have i think you know over time
you know when you feel a certain way
about something you get steeper
in your convictions and in the 17 years
since love actually
uh my convictions have been steeped and
gotten steeper and have been solidified
with this most recent viewing that i had
i was not wrong in my initial opinion
about the film
it has gotten stronger because of
elements that have
not aged well particularly its depiction
of
most of the women in this movie i think
it is a
terrible romantic comedy and as far as
christmas movies go
i would rather watch eyes wide shut
all day long than love actually again
we went there it will love actually
might actually have more nudity
than eyes wide shut lucy because i
forgot about how much sex
is in a movie that feels pg-13 but maybe
my biggest issue with this movie
is that every year my family wants to
sit down and watch love actually because
my mom and my sister love it and so you
sit down but you always have that
awkward moment where you're watching
gratuitous sex
and a lot of nudity and your mom's right
thing
it is awkward i don't to be honest i
feel like you could even though i love
martin freeman you could just cut that
part out because
i think they would have made more money
because i know that a lot of families
watch this film and they have to fast
forward through that part so
it's kind of like does it add to the
story they're it's like they're both
cute actors but it's just very
um and to your point scott you mentioned
richard curtis is directing i just want
to say real quick
that's his directorial debut he did a
pretty damn good job because number one
look at his cast
he got great performances out of people
and that is hard to do as a director
secondarily he has some killer
transitions in that movie
i know at the the wedding reception
they're playing that one song and then
it bleeds into the funeral
uh when joanna the deceased wife of liam
neeson
you know is playing that fun song so
little things like that where
i think people usually um don't don't
think about that in terms of directing
but that's
that's hard stuff to think about so
there are moments where he kind of kills
it and i i'm
pretty damn impressed that's his first
movie that he directed
so so there now now i get to ask the
question
that is gonna be equally difficult
whether you ever hate the movie
jacqueline starting with you what is the
one storyline
that you think about the most that that
you enjoy the most
from love actually doesn't necessarily
have to be the the most uplifting one
but i'm gonna guess you're sticking with
the little drummer boy
no actually although i do love that the
the thing i love most about
that is actually liam neeson coaching
the kid and then the final scene
but the storyline i like the most for
like
so many reasons is actually the andrew
lincoln one
like i'm not gonna lie to you i live for
that for so many reasons
first of all it's messy as hell and i
love mess
second of all he's one of the finest
dudes
in the piece um also it hits on like
some interesting weird things about the
movie like the fact that
keira knightley was like 18 and like two
minutes after playing
the fake princess amidala and here she
is like as it's supposed to be this like
adult marrying
chihuatel eja4 which i don't know what
the what the
timeline is on that age difference but
it don't feel right
um so i'm not about it um
i was gonna say scott have we won
jacqueline over to ours no
no but then on the other side i go back
to the scene
where she figures out that he's in love
with her because it really just plays on
his face and like the pictures of keira
knightley looking very angelic
and that scene is so brilliant because
it doesn't do what you expect it to do
you would expect there to be some grand
declaration and maybe oh you're with the
wrong person and i love you
no it's very much he's like oh no this
is bad
this is gonna be so bad i need to run
away from this
oh maybe i need to come back to this
nope definitely run away
also keira knightley reason why she has
a hat on in the scene she had a spot
also known as a pimple and if you look
at the scene
of her in the boat like driving away you
can actually see the pimple oh
they filmed it later and so it's like a
whole thing
and so like just rewatch that scene also
um
you realize that andrew lincoln's
character is an artist and i'm pretty
sure although i'm not positive i think
i've heard this somewhere
the art that's on display at alan
rickman's office
is his art because he shows those little
santa nipples which personally for me
what doesn't say christmas like santa
nipples i thought that was very funny
when he just yelling at the kids that
it's art andrew lincoln's yelling at the
kids laughing at the butts
that it's art and scott i guess we got
off lucky here i'm sure there was some
big uh
pimple-shaming scene that richard curtis
thankfully cut
from the finished version of the film if
i have to give you scott mance a guy
historically not known for loving love
actually your
favorite storyline which one did you
resonate most with
well i i said this at the top uh you
know the story that i love the most is
bill nye as the the the aging rock star
who was a cross between mick jagger and
robert palmer
i thought the story line with his
manager who
has stuck with him through thick and
thin
i've loved that it's a that it's a true
love story between
two almost like lifelong friends who
have
been there for each other and had each
other's
backs it is different from all of the
other
love stories in the film and it was the
one that resonated to me the most
that they're both sort of alone on
christmas
and bill nye leaves elton john's party
to go spend it with his manager and i
just thought it was very touching
uh that that moment uh i would love to
just have seen
just a movie you know bill nye is uh
he's a great actor when he does comedy
like this
and about time about time and
also when he does drama he's uh a superb
actor
see for me it it very easily could have
been that bill nye manager storyline
because
bill nye's manager is in the film
throughout and he also gets made fun of
her being heavy
and then bill nye does show up like
scott said at his door to celebrate
christmas with him because
he knows he's alone i just feel like
that scene was so mishandled i
i was ready re-watching it to have this
great love moment but it just gets to
this weird thing where it's like wait
wait are these guys going to make out
is this is bill nye even supposed to did
is he here on purpose
it just didn't seem like i wanted bill
to say i look like
i i wanted to be this sweeping christmas
emotion and it just kind of felt like
well i guess we're here let's get drunk
and watch porn
and it just didn't quite work the way
that i guess in my head
maybe train from all the other story
lines in the movie that it was going to
work and so
i'm going to say that it actually is the
alan rickman
emma thompson storyline because i want
to see that full movie
i want to see more rowan atkinson and i
also want to see
the end of the film in my cut which is
where
everybody's at the airport and we're
wrapping up all these story lines and al
rickman shows back up after a month
being away wherever he was
his kids are happy to see him emma
thompson gives him the cold shoulder
then i want some rom-com hunk to show
up i want morris chestnut to show up
right next to emma thompson put his arm
around her and say hey
i'm the step-dad that's what i want emma
thompson
to leave this movie happier than she did
lucy
that's my storyline what's yours if you
had to pick one
so i'm glad you guys both brought up the
emma thompson
and the bill nye because you know for me
it's tied with three
and you guys already brought up those
two it's the three story lines that make
me
weep bitterly sometimes sort of happy
but um tears i watched it again
a couple nights ago and i could not stop
crying
because of the emma thompson alan
rickman scene the heartbreak there
and the way she holds in the emotion to
go back out and kind of be like
everything's fine status quo like
that's so real like i've had those
moments where it's like
yes i was just crying in the closet now
i'm out and everything's fine i'm gonna
just
shove it down status quo so
and then bill nye when joe the manager
when his
his chin is quivering when when the love
of his life comes back the deep
friendship there
but i think for me the number one
beautiful and heartbreaking scene that's
my favorite storyline
is the laura linney storyline
um because you really want her to get
with santoro
i forget his name in the movie but her
very attractive
co-worker who they clearly really care
for each other
and she um
you know there's a scene where they're
getting intimate and she keeps answering
the phone it's like
girlfriend stop please stop answering
that phone just like
make it happen with this guy and
i you know personally speaking you know
i have
you know family members right who are
mentally ill
that i have that experience of like just
got to answer the phone
so it was so real for me
and then the end scene of her sitting
there sorry to i don't want to bring the
mood down but the in scene of her
sitting with her brother who has this
illness
and she's made him a scarf and they're
just staring at each other
and they love each other and then they
hug each other it's just like
that storyline alone all the other crap
the fat shaming
the the the sometimes poor treatment of
women in this film
that alone to me redeems it all because
it's so
powerful it is self-sacrificial
love she chooses her brother and taking
care of him and his feelings over her
own
and to me not only does that encapsulate
the christmas spirit but encapsulate
what love is
actually ah wow
having a perfect way to end the podcast
yeah however you can say it's powerful
you can say it's manipulative and people
will say whatever they want about this
film until the end of time but scott
much to
your chagrin i imagine this is gonna be
one of those films that continually has
talked about especially this season
year after year decade after decade
jacqueline i just have one thing
because i want to know i want to because
i think that the like naysayers on this
episode y'all got the better of us not
because you're right but more because
it's kind of hard to just be like but i
love it
but if you need further evidence
there was a literal internet riot people
were petitioning and calling people
because
netflix took love actually off of its
place oh my god on december 1st
and people in the uk lost their
collective minds
so anything that can inspire that level
of like
we can't have it i mean they're
literally like like drug addicts and
they're
now like going through withdrawals like
they were literally upset
you can find the article mark hoffmeyer
gave it to me it's legitimately
people were like i guess there's a thing
in britain where you can like report
issues with broadcasting and it's like
the same thing they did to report the
fact that they didn't like
you know that the super bowl like shows
janet jackson's nipples like the british
version of that
hundreds of letters about love actually
there is something to be said
there is something to be said about a
movie
that year after year gets brought up and
talked about jacqueline if if there are
people
who were so incensed that it was taken
off netflix that they protested
that says something i mean my personal
feelings aside
the fact that a movie can inspire and
touch people so deeply
and that mark we can have a conversation
like this that
lucy you can refer to a movie as
brilliant three times in one sentence
there is something to be said about that
film about any film that can
inspire people like that personal
feelings aside uh
i love that a movie can year after year
can can instill this kind of passion and
debate
because that is what movies are
all about yes and to all
a good night you know what you can
actually you can find this movie
uh if you are worried about where you
can stream it it's on fandango now and
voodoo currently available on both those
platforms
i do have a quick bit of love actually
trivia that i want to get to at the end
but first
scott mance you and lucy were both are
his team guests today producer lucy
she wore her producer hat valiantly but
she also was an amazing
guest so i want to get a streaming
recommendation from each one of you
something else maybe that's not love
actually but you think
could accomplish what love actually set
to do better
scott do you have a streaming
recommendation for all the
kitties listening well uh i i don't know
if it's streaming
um but it is you know on demand
you can uh rent it from itunes it's only
two but
three bucks uh that counts that that's
in the stream
uh okay uh elf elf
elf to me is the best
holiday movie of the 21st century
uh director by john favreau
and starring obviously will ferrell it
is
such a wonderful heartfelt
funny crowd-pleasing movie
for the entire family kids grown-ups
it is it was an instant classic when
it came out ladies and gentlemen the
same year as
love actually 2003 it is a classic in
every sense of the word
i love love love that movie if you can't
find it on like you know
like the netflix's and amazons and
hulu's of the world rent it
to get the blu-ray it's it's a it's a
brilliant movie lucy yeah
how dare you crush that year and
the the basically love actually had to
go up
against elf the matrix
revolutions i think master and commander
bad santa
it had a lot of competition when it was
released in early november but it just
kept choogling so it was a modest hit
at the time and now it's just this this
monster thing that we all talk about
lucy do you have a
streaming recommendation that can give
the kids some love actually oh i do
also i love your usage of the word
chugalin that was those cute
i feel like me and john fogarty the only
ones that still use chugulan so
i like it let's bring it back um yes
okay so i just started watching the
walking dead so um
jacqueline to your awesome scene i also
agree with you about that story line uh
andrew lincoln
watch him fight some zombies finally got
on that train so i'm in season three
and oh lucy let me
nothing nothing nothing first of all
good that you're on the walking dead
yeah
there's going to be a point where you're
like no actually there's going to be
several points where you're like no
push through like okay through the pain
okay push through the pain okay and
you'll know it when you get there
i mean i'm investigating so i'm giving
you the opposite advice i if you're on
season three
i am grabbing your cheeks like billy
madison grabbed those kids cheeks and
said stay here as long
as you can i'm gonna push guys i'm gonna
push through
the other streaming thank you for that
advice by the way i do appreciate that
um
the other show that i just finished i
binged it in like two nights
the morning show speaking of problems
uh not not the show that the show's
amazing but it deals with
all sorts of stuff uh and specifically
i'm
an absolute awe of billy crudup
crudup and his performance in that show
so if you've not seen it
get apple subscription stuff i know it's
one more just
just do it just trust me guys all right
i promised everyone
a little bit of love actually trivia
much to scott mance's chagrin this is
not going to be a movie release dates
question
scott so it might be a little outside of
your expert zone
we're gonna start with you and then
we're gonna get a guest from jacqueline
and from lucy and everybody else
listening just shout it whether you're
listening to us at the gym in your car
wherever you are on the toilet
shout out what you think the correct
answer is which
character in love actually
has the most amount of screen time laura
lenny
there's there's only two characters that
have over 30 minutes
and this person has 32 the silver
catalyst has 31 minutes so
lucy says laura linney scott mance says
hugh grant
jacqueline coley your guess hmm
uh this is hard hold on let me think let
me think let me think
let me think flip up because
i'm competitive and so i at least want
to think about it if i'm gonna have a
wrong answer i at least want to feel
like i thought about it
i'm gonna actually say fine
god i feel it's either laura linney or
hugh grant
laura lynn one just under the buzzer
jacqueline guesses laura winnie everyone
is wrong the answer is emma thompson
with 32
minutes of screen time hugh grant
has 31 minutes it was my second
it was my stuff everybody was
oh so close and i'll say for this
episode today it was
a lovely spirited healthy
debate and it ended up being a battle of
the sexes and much like the movie itself
the men won because they were right
so with that being said
definition of mansplaining too because i
don't think i know that either
you want to give me that quick
definition i am not going to win that
fight so i'm simply going to
remind everyone that scott mance has a
youtube channel
that you can just go to youtube and
search scott mance and he's gonna pop up
scott
i know you're a big beatles hunk and i'm
sorry that this movie wasn't all you
need
love actually but what can you tell us
about the other cool stuff you're
working on
well like you pointed out so i got my
youtube channel which is just
scott mintz uh doing my own film content
which i learned how to do this year so
uh something good came out of this year
and yes if you live in
the southern california area you can
catch me on
friday mornings on ktla tv channel 5
there are any
winning morning broadcasts and follow me
on twitter and instagram
and it is so great to talk movies with
you on rotten tomatoes i am a big rotten
tomatoes fan
i miss seeing you in person jaclyn i
miss
i definitely miss seeing you at toronto
at telly ride
at sundance and i really hope we can get
back to doing these
in theater meetups again really soon
when it is safe in the meantime be safe
and happy holidays and happy new year to
all of you
happy new year happy new year to you
scott you literally are you see so many
movies where it has the embodiment of
the christmas spirit you
are the film celebration spirit every
time we go to a screening we're lucky
enough to get invited to a cool event
usually the ones that you are hosting
and moderating panels and you just light
up the room you make everybody feel like
a million bucks
last question for you real quick i know
you are a big beatles fan it's the
christmas season which christmas beetle
tune is better is it paul mccartney
simply having a wonderful christmas time
or is it john lennon's happy xmas war is
over
okay well that is a great question mark
ellis i've always been a bigger
mccartney fan
but i'm going to give the edge here to
happy christmas war is over by
john and yoko it's a better song but
having said that
i do love wonderful christmas time i was
at the grocery store the other day and
it came on
and uh you know there i am in a grocery
store wearing a mask shopping trying to
get in and out of there
and it did bring a smile under my mask
when i heard paul mccartney's wonderful
christmas time can't stand the wonderful
christmas one love happy xmas war is
over so i am going with jon
on this one for everyone here our
hard-working crew behind the scenes our
producer who is now a star of the show
lucy bruckner and my steam co-host
jacqueline coley we love hearing from
you tell us what you love about this
episode tell us your feelings on love
actually and
of course let us know future episodes
that you want to hear us based which
movies should we be talking about that
are fresh that you think
should be riding a rotten movies that
you love email us anytime
rt is wrong at rottentomatoes.com you
can find jacqueline coley at
that jaclyn i am at mark ellison whether
you love
actually or whether you hate love
actually we appreciate you
enjoying this podcast click like uh
wherever you're able to
rate review all that good stuff and like
jaclyn said we'll see y'all next week
for how the grinch stole christmas i'm
mark ellis for everyone here we'll talk
to you next week
you